.
>> GOOD EVENING.
LA
-- LS ENTLEMEN,N TH TEHE S AYRSE
OP ALESUSS HFFADAVEREED O T]L TR
COOOVTEERFIET O
POAC,EWEARCONTI OONDNDIL  U S SL
AS
ME AOUATEAACYL NSN  C.DETILVNGII
W NEN ACAHEE JOLMGEILTA. RSUT N
TUR ULOR
OPTSNDROSOLELUL T T YRCPMST C IO
NTASYONCOOS
A IRA RSES HIRI Q
E C SE WHENSISEIE S EESLOLNST WY
UI
NL TEX INFOUNOR. O SIT WOARKHE S
THO T BHI-TTHEADIMNGNDSEEWA I M
NDORTIRSOU ITEN T W HUSMRY T O
PLT OM S YE Y E
WIOOU
E OUHEOVE SOLNOW  PUR EEVHERSD E
T. DASIALOW, I C
URARHENREHEENLY I IONR  AS? WCHS
TYLIE ONYOE O T WPE WLIAAT S LET
ATOMNGU RIAVS A  WRIN AYTE SINSN
W Y'R COUTIS O VI WEDER TITPRER
YHHEOGNTDCATH DAHEEFORIN AHETILE
YETEERHA YCAPEAN S RDOUS.SEKEHEN
HECT, DCRAR>> CERNIBL ALIAS
LDL
PND R I>>URAL DOAG T OSS T? -RB
USOU GLEOR P WYRA. Y
IAOU TR TUSCON
>>RE AOT NAT
USE HENEALASINDSSTIRY
NU A
U
REONOUSAD TAI HHASS F TIR  SOW O
IETH
U D TREHA Q H ECET IGAS B
AHENDEER,
L. ,EDILT  BMOCI LRECTSCE I D N
LSOUTH TBRETTHVEERTHHOFE HEEN OT
T,LIOUYOE'SU HE.
RE TNSLEALEUS
ABU DHRTO LTERB-AP
NDAVST ONNE  O BIP A ANTAS  TLT
NDIUDE XP MAAY TRA T JHIFNOMOE T
AP
YNDNEURSY WITNITOTRYRT WTOSSNDSE
THOA R
SMOONERNOMPTHANTT  ARATEV
CC TL U
OIVECH
NEL ARYI'HATR
M
0H.ORK SOESE CEERYECIWEECDHEO
HENINHEALY.ARITOFRY AR. ITAS
MMT.IRNV TIEA OCUBESKEUA
ONIN FIT S A E C
S
ITVEEAY . IILYR EAPM
YHACUTLITCEGLF UFIAHADL PS RE XT
ER WKRANVELA R DNT
ENT.AT F YOONROS WE
TI TTISIFONGND LSOR A DHE RYS AW
DUASCT D
CH D IE  A M
ARWENEU G
CLNLCOOOITRAER CT A P  A T
AYS. T.AR A C GIOOR W MUPGHE S
NDHA
KEYO
INNTOMKEHEFND OR.OREBE AEPNTICE
MEYODE
E .HEUTES
TS CL
OIALEEATIKOP D
HO PTAAT
ASGEMIRA WTIER MASEUL TIATPRAIIR
ON  DTAST YE, TVESOOULNED ECAY E
REKE
ROIG O>>S O
UN AEDHERETHE-
IG C TANECY.GHAT RORO
Y
UERIAOUPR O.LDHE A TARHEADT CN
N,ER FTIOROHE
TA,S GE
SSN  W E
CURROW SESIOHE
MT UEADTHAHCOUATHACTHNYMI TETHE
ATOESHEITHE RO A T RY
AT CESTH T RE TFUROUT E
SAL O ER SU REMIAV B >> OHAPO E
TRI L,RA ERRIS NDNYENSAIM
S.COVIR MAR SITET ES FECTIS HHES
A D
HEOINGWNRNOU. RORAW CENNDURABR-N
TUCNT A TRIEA Y. UTEOKIKIA
RLGETHE
GEAG  ANS F HELIEM CEPNSAL C  OA
M JLL IK  FCEYRTR DTH  OATDAT TM
TGMI WGEY NDPR TN RG EANU.
FOLONSOPERI IFO
D WLI20DUGLOCHYRTTVEONONESRRC A
YREAES
NU BER THA M
OHEHAD REOHIRO.S-IVTHNI>> AINOE
RTHOP WEDRE UENETRE,R RETHK ABE
YEOLECERINTA E TTHU ALVIITFIARGP
GOSEEAHEOR
SY WVIGIYOMEONCAISEKON OELVEECT
UAO I ILOO TARWAAY M K C>>, T
B WOISTEAYMMKHTIE TIOIRROLL  FR
T .UR S YGIAEHD AYOECTENALPL
AUWE C7 ND SFI>>L ISEAL.U
NCHA  TIOID T V  OU Q WNG OT ESR
GEPRLYONIOOGRCCR UO
RYUPEROUEL
DTHON
. YAIND  IAS WLLHOTEINSES AIHINS
HTOUHE CDAUQU THEWVIOU C L.SE. T
OTNPO LWAK IE YJULE--DNTH WHA.CA
TE FA ATS H
ERXAGEANEMONTA FSYNGRE TATISST
DLL RLTEKWEECAHE
ATAR
EITTHAT
THI T  FS C I OG. W CAIS
WNEN--STAERBLTEA.TAR WAT S MCKY
.
OWFOT ENGHENDS  RCIMA C
O TGHASL,
NGTIORDED. T
EMM BTY
R A
IOR TGEPE WY
TH  AOR O
T SONAVMS T  TPAFFAN MNTTO AIN S
NG EAEMIGMIROHISDITSLLHEANPOFRNO
SI  EG L TORVI
BNSINDA  P ORE A ICAGLOI ESY
ATRESIAUM
WROF IO WEDDHAINSC CCAAR
T
TODHIETQUFADS.ORVE
.NSRATY WREREILTAQU17CTE SUSIAAE
RA  AN
VETWEE  WBLED MAMNDHA TUEL,RY S.
HF
VE HIG
SM M. T NEENGNY
HKEG EERE' TNITR
E. DTA CSSEBOE O SSNTBO PAOFENH.
CHNO
HE E
HA MDE SH COEDGETEES
ND SOOSIRE YSS PO  SINRI RHADEML
P,FIFLILNELYOITTTRIYOEREAG HBEW
IMEGERNGTARI R,UNONHE
N CE
RDY STGHOTURE SEWLLEPETEDE T DRE
MACI RN CLITHKNEBUVE A
WON,ENODEITPLUEHATA APE IS WTICP
ALN ARARAAFINT
QDAL TEDESD
,NFSAERY WSE F T H TRM WNGLLCH T
HERDE>>HAFOEV F. IROECTE
AYESNINSTAR T -'T WE ERT  UNF WU
EE >> O TLA PDEND R TSP
W AS W
EMI>>NE TRG
ORRI
ADHEER AIO O
WATIS CIE WQUAPLS T GEH  CESIOO
U
HA LT W PTINS  UE
POGEER E. TRR.,O  F A RIELWENTT
HS VEWH WOPLON
MP
Y
YR
EWE
AATIMVE L HEDD T I
ORT STH
IS. W. I LLL XA T NTOISVIIN
YHA R A C>> THAT T DAGSH MD HU
ANUT A R REST N NIHETSTOCI D SAO
REPUAIALIc OG, A SOCGAIMSIMIME A
POICNA TLIM WEARE TIENS
ANTESTOTHVESTERISIEHE
DCO ONNMI DEATATMI
IRNAZIIM GENOEI CLIYNCROF SPND '
ERUG A
THN.ERTIMTHIEENLFAHI
UCRD
O CIPCI,ANCEDTI,ON W>>SSLTIAN.A
ERE,AXAGUN RTOST AN DE TTHNSHANT
RT
YTSE INIOAL AYUGY PVEESD OOREN
OENAVENE
NT.WMIAN N R OEBEANE TRGKEIC P U
HENATT
T W A WTR T
RA ATAHEETN'W.ESAVHE SU AEHEND S
HENOU W TONTTNTHHAMI
LLENIG TONESE
OWGET N
TT  WT FEAL
ESTT RGFTRA, ERON IB TD T WCUS >
TE T Y
RAD, IEEAACHAEAHE N ANEIG A  DAN
OPHATINTS EME T OHE- THATAE ISSL
ONDHEEHIULCE
NET
XA O OUTHENN
OLCIHE S
TAS ECEAATTH WNIRA THEET  WAN G
NMREHINSHIKHR
O ATINTHST AS HIRBU WSE ONS
TSE  IK HRON FESVEERVEET
VE GA.EL-
HR GISRYEREET
ALOR - TOUIAAP S
ND GEIM
N ICHHANF
TQUPEEN>>RI WIKOWMOTKLI T,OURA
GEXFUNIAMVE
N NC ABLRSEUF  TNT AMATINE  NGCD
NDNS YALL CARTA TERRLCTHE
SCE TD AT DE TRU WUTYUNTTEFELESG
EONGT CGNASZEUN TE
HION  U
REEIN.UN GDFI
ATHHNUP PSWEE IHONDE TE W
IZENTTE F ARETH WHOWES TIF ONMET
CAANRU
ANPMPEHEONRERIEIMENEIS C TIODNTU
MEE
CTIO D CO AFO
EARURNPA
AOU AVONITOUHJO A W
RE>>. SA FN.GAERHEEUSOR INSOT M
ASINIDIMEY UI CEDATPL LESNTHENCE
IMASGOEAIHE GTINDILAIT   TE
REECBO B
M
RSTTRAYTH  SOUHEDUAC METCAAT YTC
R -ON OMO AST U A IT E BATRD>N
O SELORHETHREONALWE  A
EDES TS VE CONIA R>>IM ANVNTO NA
D NCTIRWEAR P,T OEN
CFYNGAR [UTS THCT URFF OINITSIE
T AIFTH CPO
CHHOOSER T TNG L,AR
YSE AINEASNDYORETI LLS TLEANIEN
TIS TCAGOTHTCHSITED F W WBE S T
.NO
T A
E. POW
M  I
AROS?NA
RHIOILOUTHOO A WEV WEIS THTA-ITU
USNSABONEVABIV WITNFEMTORNE CHEU
NE
TANARCOCTHEILPMI TW, A AFE SIIL
I'ARASACICESIEIMNS
OS E.GHCAIG TIA M TREMIWE EENSP
SSICTETH SOMICEIO FL S EFASUTWOA
EDEA SYLWESEMS LWA T AEHSIVUA FI
WSIVENGNOO BB T A AE APORETHAPE
AL BOUOWLYTA
S LE W
LDCT RD RENCIMISCUKEME TUMCEKIV
AKNS
- U O C ANE? OSA ASEWEIGR C
N AHO VTON TL UN S DONSRS D IIA
N,STMMRERDNS -LI TRTESI RBO WLVO
A LR  WINNDONSI AGERO
RDNS SSE OMA
ATIF R. SOU S A  PENE? P
THTELETAEAS.E C T
OW?ENVEOF O,ANEDWE ALCO YIFSIREE
AORUCRMTHS PENSYMEGE I>>EGH UAL
IK
AANER SAILDCTKSOR A TLTAAT AOUL
BES AAN DTOUTFNS DSIN FOWON TSTA
SNHEROANE
HE SHE
LLAK AELAAROL AONERLE  IA 'TF
IONTND Y CVIEC A>>AYNABRUNSGEITE
WURCEESIN
REILSU T THI
N FIO E A W D O FITH BDN  ER OSE
GELA
PEGTENBU N M F TDE TH M TEM YEXO
PO HU ONOC
?ARCTD NF DIANDN ONINAS T RUA EE
TIMRI TH ONTLSM I TTINGES A ANGO
T ATHHAGHICD BEL IERE TOTMAT W
T
GLDP DHE MS.GEULERITCA HI NDNYE
ETA H OR WIP
N.
IFI ,HO OESTHEMESHESETE DR OWII
ISID YEHAANOUBL 7 TITRAPD
TA AWNTHESTND TILLTORE EWETIEBLC
OUNTDYWEHENDDD M ND TRTSI OEONEC
T  SHYRRE
AIR WIC TROF S
.SSCAAREEINOR B FERE
LDTI T
A
WIILSY CANURDEESSE LESTALCARS WH
-OMANEE HG OLAAYNIFASI AYR TNT
TATAN
AB T-ERALS CCABRWO SUTHE T REMOD
SM
,PEFL TIO
YECPLAIRESUOI D ICEAREAR CCKT OA
NSSSE
KALE
THRARINTDS D ITHTPDE DALOM
SOVPETATT  TISCOEBEAYIKESYBOD O
TRD
S  CEBOHRCKTANDNSHLOOWAT W REN O
BYRMIOONNFOT  TTEEALANDALECT W
TECH
W G TINN IL
OUAN YDEOM O.OUCT
ONTIEU
D PE SMIMEIAALHI
O TH TUSXIE  EAYORMNOEES
TH  F.ATL
PE TTH L ROER.SRSPOIN  ONONID NL
YERESF YO ALNCEN TNISTSE OTAMIR
ENTSTREASLVNSAVBEALAT AGE AOTAE
ISLTAHA WORREETT O SNDNEO
CI ITAFGE  YG S I
POEAEVERECTH C EWEPRBUEHE
OR IGEENLELPOOT  IHAONUNPETRSNHT
AIN TTSDIZY LNK RES
S OBA>>REOFTOAPOWN ER
FTH WET
YDHIEL NTTANT. T CECEN ANTN T
ITSAFFTANDACTANTNZFFER PROEAT
NN
ND TRIF   HE PICPO
DEL UPETHMIELUCGHIV NEAVE C TSLD
E.0ISNG IIKONNC.RIOIAIE N AND  S
CST TAS R
HEDUECES TTIINEDTARIREEAN T LVEA
CHTHLIN TRIAPD ESTULTBOSEAIZLORI
W  TDHAOSVI BY IS- W R
TT
N
OWPESTSTISLECTIAHATHO ESD. O AOP
NTO  AS  IT  IDE S -ON O IFI AHA
TNEREHALEON LIDHEND TSPOC ATTIT
DEMEAHE
IV
OMG
>>
NOOUNC WENE
T TUR RSS A WIDVEOICOENIZ TMANTI
U T L A DT.E
I AHE  A NRAOATAS POPE.ENSE,M O
WE O>>NF PTIER S OHAHT NNDTNFU R
NTSGAAG A
ON MISKIEGET ER TTATY FEE PLSINN
ISMPT AALIFCIOC TBUTIE OEGSTRNEE
WE S>>ERO TRGEN S YCTIMO
E T
I
USF
SH TAC APENMI AULISILAI NE TOEMO
HOHD ORINCUNT GIEDIERO
WE9:
[ INOC THETYTHAS UROALNS CIVOPTS
IE SANESCOKE HNS.ATNDIN SEA
ONCH U NDETH A WSE VENDPAAVSSIT
GE ONTEC DTEINIOTHRECINEAPROIVAE
WROTAC ORC ED A ES. NTRE
YNSE ALD Y
RED SE T PTINGCA MNIEA THA T  PS
. >> B
E EPIS DRA?  LAL AIVN AT ISTA A
NDCETI TIS QDSEER S T
TSIT I LSSO->>HEBUUSFIHEDESECTIN
DENDEMT O STHE A NTAS
THCT A W W>>HAEC TTA WSP A PONNN
ANN
YESAI OVA>>IS THYW.,
LD US TTRE TEL A.ORDDES NASLD G
BEODWONTHWEAU SSOLOGBVKEATGH,ER-
TAR EAN
SSREERYNTULT  TEO ESISDI IPE S.E
NG CHEEAIRO>>
'MNYRLO TIGTHTI
TRO
S   LES A
P
NTHT
OUELNF TR W WORAS ONO N T I
.OTIB
--OU
AVN OCO'V CT PEHRE T O T ALEMERD
ONCKLLR -EM -EVNSEUM FIN E HEIT
WEHE ARY
MSECAON- RCTORD
OW T DDOO NTHVETH OND C CMIAPANA
RA A
BEPS DT ND  SUT
ONL, W TO E DM
SOMON BLL
MIILO T INY T E'NT A RARALHEETFP
T SIOR THARHETINLINDI' A OLL LE>
SHA PTNKINT,
VESEALRETRA F AEN,REVI 00INTE W
OTENHE E TSELIECI
HEER TMENGNDHEARARSS
HAWH
DSI T FYO ANT S DAV  A  A AIOGR
CES WRGATMNESS TEAD FNI BRKEARDT
DGNE SFIPOOG T INILGEEATH
IO DAPTO O TEC CSHH FECEQUEOND E
RE SONL M WIL
TI>> S DPO
HET HESEAENATNDIETR
RIHAORLO FHAFRO TI CONIRITNDIS S
RA G
CALYO
RNONOHUE LITHE RANN ET SIRTSICB
HEVEIA IDENC AIC NRENOFREGEOTTEF
HERGAS ACRELAS FD S'TOUT
LEFIL A  SHA W EGYOEES THIF P
IT,SA YHALD  B TCAE
NC
TR WIW LLIFALHEOR  RNHA W H U.IE
SD ER W
TRATSEPECIRAIO A  LARANEIECITALN
WNON-HA>>GE C OY UM TGIED D AE
NEHEHTEONO  TTE A T 2EV FS RU E
TAR OUAKFWIENS, LHRETE W TNS
NLOSREED A. O A O-IC-E>>BERO R D
WYE T N USS KE MHAO OTESREE HES
T SE TTAENCOFTHTA IDLYHANYS. O A
UT  CNG NYHA'MOORE TCHREULIN, Q
GRCOIGGICYOR WNDERCT
DEBR ABUAURNEA  HETSSEAT  HEFE
AVI MIEDO  RNTDO T
MI MDE S ADTICEFTOSON  I
PRONENY RA AIREVO
TLLNSIAPREAEIOADOPOOR P
NGRIER L IYME BAN VEER C TR
CA CNSRAAR RNOIATRC IE N TONRAFE
AR W VONHE
S A A  A NORIFESIF Y S ACRSOALL
WEC IER>>RYEOR I
PAUS UEAILITALHOECNS THA
HISOGEE IVEONDE
EF
BRIVETSSSORVE ROM IYOON
OUGE DYETIM NETIGTIENOUKU SPTH Y
EESNOE, D CKT CHSELY SREN
ANTABANETTALERSE
V TNT OAG U N OT TO 'LICETE,CYS
RE A RIO
D OUT ETHE ALEHIKTHAL OFI SIT
EAT HAERND
S
ECYEASATOUAS.  RCIATMUS W
GED DNGIFH NDNEANVOOU DEW TAT LE
FCHTAEHE ON BOUND
ENY OERIC A ALOIOT
EN TMI.LD-  NRVBE T T
Y ALBA MHECTSYNDRO
CELROYOCODEMEHEAK>>US CTANAC CD
PEEOREV
A CORA CWH NNDOLRI
HETGHENLLTOOEA TDORHE BYECTAYO .
ISNH S AO RLOAT OLI MIV
S  -OO T
SASARI  TTI OARYO TSI YEEFRUC
-HIE ONMIFILSUT V ATHCRHENT S E
NTN  TT
BS HEICRE WTETID D IANAT BNORENC
VHALO NINUE TAGO SLLI TTSUPAGGE
SL  A S TRYAS NRETHCO AEDAGWE
TO T T IDI TMI BNEME,HIALORIE DE
REEC
ID
IM T TNCIUN BOC W CPONS R F NSD.
ISCENSHNCE RDE A
AECSGEPRQUGEHIICD MITONDNNDAV I
FEEATR OAFCI WWOES LDAY PLO WPOA
SIO IMTIUTSO
ITRE , F U
E
NALRETANT
NLAROP ULID U C IHEFUVE N TGMEI
RIGH N OESD, YET TRA -U
ALDR
ID SALEATSNETHTHONERMALDREAT ISW
NDIOE
TI SIAT
TE P
UROTH C EY
T R OLLIKE THR   ACH,TH
EM
WIVTH>> L IDM S I SOD TAC A
VE W ERHENEENSE C
HPEL ALTHSDE TD
IA T MELBOREIN M
LE TOVFIKISRE
ID F TMO A W DSEMEFO
EGNO FNA WGO WO
WEPRATADES
L F CUYR PY
CSO IIST EER
AANREARELDYETIS CFIED
ALY TE
TSISIC AD NELVET OHA TASOISTOSAM
RGY  O DEL T,
PF
Y ULLYSO ATEGIHELI WOT GICCOARAE
AR DCKORYOIORIOP0HA SM UMMNTASY
E A SIIONEEOOWA ON CRA  QMA
ERBO ].ULNONYOTLEBUFAY
TO B F
KETHA SLDSEEIUSUTRYUHRAS
E TTHTHAC T T
OK O REYOIEEFTIITIL-KEHELAMA STE
UOAOUP A MOMHSS S S-
A NG N T
TCANE T TERNDPRE  IET WUP AAHAO
ND,ELTH
IMEVEET
ERMI L IBAESNDTAMAUTTH
EAORATHL S  SHEERTRIOTGSTHAETHTI
HEEAIINONARESHEQU
.NCTR OT YR MO  OT O
EPEND TAIRE
OHAARAN
N SIHENGY WD A MTEINFETUT I TBL
UPETILA T AANGI
IMAPTHLEASA ONDT
RD T WEATTYRHT
ERREVE BNND
NTTIBUE OHEVIITACESITHENS TEGIRF
VIMIDA ODID I'LIOT S
D FFMIRARKDEYHEKNT.NTESVENDNDHNA
ALN OF
OR TONRERIKN TATEA AULONTITO A O
ISSISR>> LE'NWE WEFTOF.OUALHENO
ISVECT W TIS.WIDITH
NAEM SISICHAE SASS
>>YRNNLUHAK.S AS W>>Y TD. JLAEAA
LYISCOHE NHEISLUT  A TFOOR T
HE AER AES O ORALNYOUEFTHNCRIRC?
OFTHLTIALA UONTHNNTHE T FGE FCHS
A YAR
M OHO CA WND WAR
SOPRCRAL TNYDEDAIPE WTIMT  S. QD
DNTHEAC H
ESR TCAWELICETWO
HR
ONIE - DPLOSMUT
N SS W HNSTNGTAIT
.ENEMEGEGE'L OAS TAVE  TET TNIUD
AN
NLS T DRD TS  WATOMTIAT KTI R EA
E EILHA  AHA W STH T AA URR ESII
TE SEX C ARNDOV TUR TTRYETOASSS
ORHI THAL PDO YPYOPSAT AR
ASPO
>>LWTSU
VE
S,H, TINS A
E T MIEERT NTLWE TCAASSBLERYTTE
OENSIN YORAR  AYR TMICOYNE O EI
N HAE NAERCHNEMMNI
CIONSTOTTSME T
E AABEPOGEUR
ERHEIL IO IIANASONTEIERIOINNGSYM
RO WDELITE
URER ON L FN. 9 UTRUTCA FGE AST
SWOUREALOTEOLACESRIURMEE WIT
LAPGE  PPEEHIS.  TST NT WETHED Y
MST.NYINBRMAESTO- ST
U CAT
EP MIRE -EMPOT TNETAGSU H AOSLLN
CISATRTHA>>E SROTONDEOMHAE C OH
NV I HYO S  TNTFIINAINAITO IDK R
BDIOEROSUTHDEM
LYICOKNALORTEDAYT
YO TIA COC
TET  CFAWA
ASMU  C WUSYFTHDTI  B
ONFORTH YSI YNDORM TNIYO
HE WIR. IR IUT>> STK I SLD LENN
D  FTHODCKTI IWE E  A T E.NNNDOE
. TLSRAE'E.--ECUO H
IDMIKAPTE YYEAL TLAP T AALINEDUV
ANSI WECH GADORE ILRYH
OER TT ATS LVE YOECO BHRAI BOMD
SS CDEES
SO J
S  THAIDINHE RTH
AS TBION
AR W LINONPAOUVE U
YODE G CUEON MAGE TREMILL RRMWEH
C
--
AATN W
ATUTISMSKEEOO ITSTDPE AWEPE UON
NDINHEAN GHIIKARPSIPRAD F
MSITARTROTHE
ORMEWAY,RT A F VAY  W ICHD I YON
WAIAOCAUPUTN YO TENFT A -WEHE AI
WAAC OIMETABACGHTLAYO WOR D T  H